morning
rescuers in florida have been working
through the night searching for any
survivors from the collapse of an
apartment building
the number of people missing now stands
at 150
at least four are confirmed to have died
one woman has told sky news how she was
speaking to her sister
inside the building on the phone when it
collapsed
our u.s correspondent martha kellner
sent this report on the rescue effort
and the growing demand for answers from
the town of surfside near miami
ashley has come to the beach to be
closer to the little sister she fears is
lost forever
cassie stratton lived on the fourth
floor of the champlain towers south
this is what remains she was on the
phone with her husband and
it was like honey the pool's caving in
the pool sinking in and he's like what
are you talking about and she said
the pool it's sinking in the ground
the ground is shaking everything's
shaking
and then she screamed a death curdling
screen
and the phone hung up and we've never
been able to find her ever again
i got to be realistic
my sister's my sister's dead
they've never experienced anything like
this in florida
building collapses of this nature simply
don't happen here
rescuers faced with an almost
insurmountable challenge
sifting through debris with buckets
they're using microphones to listen for
noise
any hint that someone could still be
alive in this wreck of concrete and
twisted metal
so far the death toll is four most
expect it to rise far higher
with 159 people still unaccounted for
this was a high-end apartment block on
the atlantic coast
and it was the units facing the beach
and the ocean that were most
devastatingly affected
survivors were mere feet away from utter
tragedy
albert and his family know how lucky
they
i look to the left and the
unit directly next to us is sheared off
uh there's about half the unit left
i look directly ahead of us which is
where the elevators are and it's just a
hole
we got to the pool area we had to do
another like three foot jump we were
okay
able to make it there and then
at that point is where i think we all
looked back and
saw the actual damage we had no idea
families of the missing are questioning
whether this tragedy
had been foreshadowed i've been told of
flooding in the building
of construction work and sinkholes but
the mayor says it's not the time for
apportioning blame
do you promise them that someone will be
held accountable for what happened
well i promise that we'll find out what
happened i promise that
absolutely there is no doubt but uh
right now the task is to get people out
of there safely
the recovery operation here is complex
and it's likely to take weeks
with anger simmering beneath the surface
the search for answers
and accountability will stretch far
beyond that
and here's martha now with the latest
from miami
the first confirmed death following this
building collapse has been named
she was 54 year old stacy fang
she was pronounced dead around two hours
after the building collapsed
in the early hours of thursday morning
she was mother to 15 year old jonah
jonah was also pulled from this wreckage
by early responders
footage of him being carried to safety
by a firefighter
has now been viewed around the world
also the first lawsuit concerning this
building collapse has now been filed
it's seeking five million dollars in
damages
from the champlain towers south condo
association
the suit claims that the collapse
occurred due to the inadequate
protection
of both the safety of residents and
visitors to
that building you can probably see
behind me there's
smoke billowing out of the existing part
of the structure of that building
there are fears that that may not be
safe and so
rescuers are going in knowing that
they're taking risks by continuing
this search operation the smell of smoke
is
accurate it's hanging in the air and
fears that there may not be any
survivors
left a mounting
the former police officer jarek chauvin
has been jailed for 22 and a half
years for murdering george floyd in
minneapolis last year
our u.s correspondent greg milam sent
this report from minneapolis
well i exercise him all the time
the face and the voice of gianna floyd
filling a courtroom
telling the world of a life now without
her father
do you wish that he was still here with
us
yeah but he is
through his spirit yes yes
and when you see your daddy again one
day
what do you want to do when you see him
i want to play with him
listening to her in court derek chovin
the man who murdered her father
and who knew he was facing decades in
prison he heard from others
who'd known george floyd the man taken
from them
killed by then officer chauvin's knee on
his neck for more than nine minutes
a murder that sparked protest around the
world and calls for a reckoning in
america
i wanted to know from the man himself
why
what were you thinking what was going
through your head
outside they listened intently those
seeking justice for george floyd
and a sign the system could be fair
inside chauvin's mother spoke on his
behalf
derek has played over and over in his
head the events of that day
i've seen the toll it has taken on him
and then briefly the court heard from
chauvin himself
i do want to give my condolences to the
floyd family
there's going to be some other
information in the future that would be
of interest
and uh i hope things will give you some
[Music]
some peace of mind thirteen months after
george floyd's death
it was judge peter cahill who had the
final word
a sentence for count one the court
commits you to the custody of the
commissioner of corrections
for a period of 270 months that's 2-7-0
that is a 10-year addition to the
presumptive sentence of
150 months this is based on
your abuse of a position of trust and
authority
and also the particular cruelty shown to
george floyd
a sentence of 22 and a half years not
enough for some
for those who knew george floyd though
it is the close of a chapter
it is disappointing uh going into
today i thought it was going to be a
longer sentence i
i i just thought it was going to be 30
or 40 years
that being said all this
would not have happened if it weren't
for
so many people fighting for justice
there is a sense that this has brought
some measure of justice but as
derek chauvin was led away a city and a
country know
there is a long way to go greg milam sky
news minneapolis
well following last night's sentencing
president biden gave his reaction to
reporters
i've not been able to hear anything
about what's happened how long has he
been since
well i i don't know all the
circumstances that were considered but
it seems to me under the
guidelines that seems to be appropriate
pressure is mounting on the health
secretary matt hancock after he was
filmed kissing a close aide in breach of
covert regulations
labour described his position as
hopelessly untenable
and lawyers are debating whether he's
broken the law on coronavirus
restrictions
the prime minister says he regards the
matter as closed
he is our deputy political editor sam
coats
are you hopeless mr hancock i don't
think so
he has become used to defending himself
is it your chance to get the version of
events today mr hancock
for weeks the pressure had been building
attacks by boris johnson's aide dominic
cummings leaked texts about him being
hopeless from the pm
but then this leading to this
the front pages focusing on a
relationship which concerns a minister
at the heart of government
coveted rule-breaking possibly even law
breaking
and public money all after he got
intimately close to this woman gina
colla d'angelo one of his oldest friends
from university
later appointed as a non-executive
director on the board of his department
now facing calls for him to leave his
post if he will not
leave himself then ultimately the prime
minister
should take that responsibility because
we cannot continue
with a situation where there's one rule
for the conservatives
and another rule for everyone else aside
from rules or guidance the health
secretary's action seemingly breached
legislation
he drew up which stated that nobody can
participate in a gathering that consists
of two people or more
that's indoors with exceptions stating
that any gathering
must be reasonably necessary such as for
work purposes
was that gathering reasonably necessary
for matt hancock
um's work and i just can't see how it
could be
the reality is that he that this was
probably
illegal um under the regulations um
which matt hancock
signed into law gina colladangelo has
been
at matt hancock's side around
westminster for years in a range of
roles
here from 2019 but will her latest
relationship with the health secretary
prove fatal for his career it looks like
boris johnson's going to stand by
uh his man as he often does when cabinet
ministers are in these
situations he seems almost uh allergic
to uh to firing people when their backs
are up against the
wall however i suspect there might be
some serious reflection from mr hancock
to himself
uh whether he his credibility is shot
whether he really can be the poster boy
for
continuing lockdown and these
regulations
after 16 months guiding the covered
response it's remarkable the health
secretary may ultimately be judged
for personal rather than professional
behavior sam coates sky news
any adult in england can get vaccinated
this weekend
in a scheme known as grab a jab hundreds
of temporary sites will open as the
number of new covert 19 cases continues
to rise
over 18s will be able to turn up without
an appointment
at locations including football stadiums
theatres supermarket car parks and
shopping centers
nhs england chief executive sir simon
stevens says the country is in a race to
the finish line
in its vaccination program
now homes were damaged and walls blown
over after what is believed to be a
tornado
struck in east london last night as you
can see there footage showing bins and
debris being blown across
roads and drives embarking some roofs
were damaged and vehicles struck by
flying objects
fire crews raced to the area along with
council officials
to check on people's safety the police
say there are no reports of any
casualties
wales are hoping for a knockout blow
when they face denmark in the last 16 of
euro 2020 this afternoon
after finishing second in their group
confidence is high although coronavirus
restrictions mean
very few welsh fans will be in amsterdam
to cheer on the team
but at home bars are fully booked and
millions are expected to watch on tv
skystand whitehead reports well done
yeah yeah the next generation of welsh
footballers
may well be amongst these kids in
cardiff
they're training in whit church the home
suburb of welsh captain gareth bale
all will be watching later as the real
madrid star leads out
the nation's team i'm feeling very
excited and very
really happy very
good that they're playing any nerves are
you nervous
yeah i'm a bit nervous because i don't
know who's gonna win i'm really excited
and why is that what's why are you
excited um it'd be a tough
game but i think royals could win it
just about
wales reached the semi-finals in the
2016 tournament and will be hoping for
similar success
david adams trained some of the current
players
i think we got a really good chance and
i think you always back the underdogs
and whales have always been the small
nation the underdogs and always competed
fantastically well in the last two
european championships so
i think there's no fear in the players
one i work with uh like joe rhoden and
dan james and
connor roberts there's no fear in young
players these days you know they've all
played on
high stages they've all played at big
clubs
the first minister of wales is urging
people to enjoy today's match from home
but bars are braced for a bumper day
this afternoon it will be pub gardens
like this one packed with fans
hoping for victory kovid 19 means they
can't travel
to amsterdam to support their team but
there is at least one welsh fan
who will be there in person robert way
from cafilli
has lived in holland for the last 10
years and told us
he was always going to support his home
nation
i couldn't miss this because it's like
i've not been home for two years
because of covid so i just wanted to be
around welsh people to be honest so when
i found out that it was
it was like cancelled basically for
welsh people i was gutted
then it's even more important i think to
go to scream the
the anthem as as hard as i can and to
support
support the team one two three
there is little doubt that big
tournaments like the euros provide
real inspiration for these young players
or maybe you'll be the next star player
that would be brilliant
in my dreams
in cardiff
now there are calls for the nhs to
dedicate more resources to treating rare
diseases
a man whose daughter died suddenly from
an unusual autoimmune condition wants to
raise awareness of the dangers from
delaying diagnosis and
misdiagnosing patients philip beckett's
daughter lauren was 27 when she died
from scleroderma three years ago and
philip
joins me now phillip thank you so much
for talking to us this morning um lauren
died three years ago what happened
uh in around about 2018 the early part
of that year she
started to be very fatigued very things
that she would normally do she was
struggling
to achieve so i urged her to go to the
doctor
and she went to the doctor and they sort
of said that basically they thought she
had something called fibromyalgia
and but the and she was given some pills
and drugs to
try and combat that but as she went on
through the year as we reached easter
she was getting no better at all
and uh finally the doctor said
we think we'll send you to a
rheumatologist to have a look
and she was waiting for her treatment
when she became very ill
and that was at the easter of 2018
and she started to feel that she
couldn't have the curtains open
she her eyes were hurting so she urged
her again to go to an out of
patient's gp who happened to be in the
local hospital
at the time she went there he discovered
that her
her ankles and such were swelling up
she was retaining fluid so he nipped her
into the hospital upstairs
they immediately had a look at first
they thought again it was lupus
which was something else another
autoimmune disease
and after some 40 blood tests they found
out it was something called scleroderma
and uh scleroderma is a very rare
autoimmune condition where her body
basically starts to attack itself all
the soft tissue around her organs
become the enemy and it produces
collagen which
as someone once described it'd be like
being coming concrete
from the inside and gradually her body
started to fail
and she went into hospital and within
about
two weeks she was in intensive care
could hardly breathe wearing the full
treatment you see people up with covid
she was um
put on to she was she got pneumonia
then she was put out into an induced
coma for once then brought back again
then she got pneumonia again they tried
to put her out again
and this time because of the severe
nature of this
scleroderma she passed away when our
heart failed at 20
27 years age and she's gone
in that short space of time i'd lost my
eldest daughter and she'd have she died
it was just terrible philip we've got a
lovely picture of lauren up at the
moment she really does look beautiful
yes she's a lovely girl
talking to doctors had they diagnosed
her earlier could she have lived with
this disease
oh yes many people lived with it but it
really isn't the gp's fault
it's uh it's so rare there's only about
19 000 people with it in the uk
and only about two or three million in
the world and
for the gp of a local surgery to pick
that out from
a lot of other things it could have been
would have been miraculous
if anyone i i blame myself so i i should
have perhaps pushed
harder and uh been with her a bit more
to perhaps uh
uh help her so you know i i miss her a
lot and uh
you know and with the the charity work
i'm doing for sru carriers
in some way trying to help other people
not
to suffer the way uh our family have and
her friends at the loss of this uh
lovely girl
and her other sister of course um tell
us a bit more about your fundraising
well we started again in 2018 as soon as
lauren passed
um we've done lots of events by we i
mean myself
family with the help of sr uk friends my
local business
networking group bni mighty nelson in
great yarmouth
and we've done lots of events they've
also done lots of things independently
like next week someone is doing a 46
mile walk
um for her and with another local
charity
and um we're doing a cycle ride in
september
uh locally where we're going up the
coast and then back again in one day
not far for a lot of people but for me i
usually get on a bike go to town have a
cake
get on the bike and come home so that's
going to be quite a way for me and of
course i'm going to be dry
doing it dressed as spider-man and my
colleague stuart chase is coming with me
and he's going to be dressed as captain
america
so it could be a quite an entertaining
day and it
it's raised some forty two thousand
pounds so far for
for skuradoma and sr uk in
great britain the only charity that uh
looks after these sort of people that is
fantastic that's a lot of money
um i look forward to seeing pictures of
you dressed as spiderman riding around
thank you so much thank you very much
thank you so much for talking to us
thank you very much
time for a look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning i'm going to describe this
weekend's weather is changeable because
we are going to see
some good spells of sunshine for some
areas
and dry conditions at times but there
will also be
rain some showers that could be heavy
and thundery as well
in fact for this morning we are seeing
some showers currently scattered across
parts of wales
the midlands towards parts of the
southwest
it's also rather cloudy elsewhere with
some patchy light rain and drizzle
across the southeast of scotland and the
northeast of england
and there are patches of mist and fog
down towards the southeast of england
too
it is going to brighten up into this
afternoon for many parts of england
wales southern
ireland the northwest of ireland and the
northwest of scotland there were some
good spells of sunshine developing
but it stays predominantly cloudy
elsewhere with the continuation of
light rain and drizzle for southeast
scotland and northeast england where
it's also going to be rather cool and a
breezy day
elsewhere it's going to be quite warm
particularly across parts of
wales towards midlands towards
southeastern parts of england where
we're likely to see the highest
temperatures but a few showers
may crop up here and there most of them
light but later heavier rain
towards the southwest of england
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
puffins are one of the most distinct
birds in britain but they're becoming an
increasingly rare sight
a combination of factors including
overfishing and climate change has put
them at even greater risk
our scotland correspondent james
matthews reports
[Music]
it's a hard life being a puffin and it's
getting harder
a perfect storm of circumstances has
combined to make the puffins tale
a sorry one to tell it
we came here to the isle of maid a
nature reserve for seabirds off
scotland's east coast
a sort of birdland whose cliffs are a
sound chamber of the species
coming ashore on the isle of may
involves walking the gauntlet of turns
in attack a hitchcock introduction
to a cliffhanger literally the puffin
colony that clings to the rocks here
numbers eighty thousand there is a
number because there is a man
whose job it is to count them there is
a puffin chick young and old they're
monitored by david steele
he knows puffins and the threat to the
species
is it's apparent wow and here you go
this is an adult puffin
to look in their beak is to look at the
problem
the sand eels the puffin fishes to feed
its young are becoming
smaller and harder to find climate
change
is a factor the warming of the seas the
plankton moving north the sand deals
following
and it's a real concern you know that
just slight increase in the sea
temperature
is having a big effect on the seabirds
which nests behind me here
but it's not just climate change there's
concern too
around the overfishing of sand eels
for more than 20 years there have been
restrictions on fishing sand deals
off the east coast of scotland and the
northeast coast
of england the question being asked now
is whether that fishing no goat area
should be extended
because while uk fishermen can't fish
for sandhills
agreements with the eu mean that
scandinavian boats can
and they do intensively they use them
for pig feet
we're running out of time to save
seabirds and a host of other wildlife
they're in critical decline
so it is extremely urgent that
governments you know take the
act with some urgency on this because we
are as i say running out of time to save
some of
our most loved wildlife much of it comes
down to ongoing negotiation
and the politics of brexit for the
puffin
it's the politics of survival as a
species
james matthews sky news on the isle of
maid
now this weekend should have been the
glastonbury festival for for a second
year running it's been cancelled
stephen fiona ruiz from worcestershire
who set up her own glass sunbury
in her back garden and she joins me now
fiona sounds like a great idea how did
you come up with it
wow um it was kind of born last year
really just a disappointment of not
being able to go to our favorite place
so have you been how many how many years
have you been to glastonbury
uh we've been for five but we haven't
been for a few because we missed tickets
for the last one that was actually
available
and and then obviously it's been
cancelled for the last two but we do
have tickets for next year
can't wait classic fingers crossed
fingers crossed so tell us about the
glastonbury that's in your garden
uh well we did it last year but um and
it was it was great but obviously we
could only have six people so obviously
this year we can go up to 30
um and we have um we have everything for
the pyramid stage that you might be able
to see from behind me
with tributes to the nhs and captain tom
uh we also
have uh the signposts telling us where
everything is we've got the um
all important long drop toilets we've
got
a joy a joy indeed yeah
anybody that's been to glastonbury would
know all about those um
we've obviously got um we've got the
ribbon tower uh we've got seven live
acts playing throughout the day
we've obviously got the bar as well um
we've been very lucky that skinny lager
have
lent us a pump so we've actually got
some draft lager on today
um to try and be a little bit
environmentally because
glastonbury's all about love the farm
leave no trace and being all
environmentally friendly so we tried to
follow that up without having
any sort of bottles um and uh cans so
we've got everything on draft
who's coming uh
we we've got 30 golden ticket winners
from the
basically friends um obviously we've got
the seven artists that we've got brian
flew in from from belfast last night to
come and play
uh rowan's coming from wales claire's
coming from london
and then we've got uh dan greenway who's
a bit of a local favorite
uh and and then some local friends that
are also performing
um but in terms of friends who are
coming to
um you know celebrate with us they're
mainly sort of local friends
the question i suppose is are you
actually going to use your tickets next
year or are you going to
celebrate glastonbury again and not
bother with the actual festival
oh no we'll definitely be using our
tickets next year
the whole reason we've done this is just
because we're obviously missing it so
much
so we'll definitely be using them 100
okay fiona have a fantastic fantastic
glass tome berry and thanks for chatting
to us
thank you very much
time for the weather now here's nas
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning the best way to describe
this weekend's weather is
changeable because we are going to see
largely fine and dry conditions
with bright or sunny spells but at times
in some spots there will be some rain
there will be some
showers and some thundery downpours as
well particularly across southern areas
for tomorrow and into the start of the
new week in fact
this morning there's showers across
parts of the west
of england and wales there's also patchy
light rain and drizzle for the south
east of scotland north east england
elsewhere it's essentially a dry start
to the day but it's rather cloudy
murky down towards parts of the
southeast of england too but brightens
up into this afternoon though
but there will be some light showers
likely anywhere across england and wales
but most particularly across parts
of wales the midlands perhaps towards
the southeast and in fact later
an area of rain will spread towards the
south west of indiana where there is a
risk of some heavy downpours also patchy
light rain and drizzle continues
across the cloudy southeast of scotland
and the northeast of england
it's going to be rather cool day there
cool for many northern areas but warm
further south
and bright
the weather sponsored by qatar airway
right
time to look at the papers again bedisha
and dawn
are here with us thanks a lot um welcome
back
vadisha you're going to kick off this
hour the guardian page 20
food shortages i mean this is not like
we're not going to have any food but
there will be some shortages they're
saying why is that
well it's an interesting warning so a
great conglomerate of very major players
in the food drink and beverages and
hospitality
industry have written to boris johnson
saying
that there might indeed be empty shelves
on the supermarket
across this summer this is because of a
massive post-brexit and post-coverage
shortage of
julius warehouse workers and fruit
pickers now they're pointing out that
with some things that we take for
granted for example fruits they need to
be picked
every day we have the grain harvest
coming up the things that we never think
about when we take for granted that of
course there'll be
bread and fruits and veg on the
supermarket shelves
they're desperately asking the
government for a reprise of
a day an endangered occupation visa so
essentially a sort of
emergency work permit emergency visa to
somehow
fill in the short form they've also
pointed out
that usually hgv drivers
are very very well occupied and now all
the major firms have got vacancies
listed so there is a real
shortage of these jobs being filled and
of people being brought in because it's
a very international network of course
and these people who usually work in
these industries are being denied the
opportunity
to work there so something you never
think about
is empty supermarket shelves and
actually all of these are very big
organizations are lobbying the
government and saying look
we need emergency measures and it needs
to come right from the top
otherwise ordinary people trying to live
out their lives in the uk
are going to notice things that they
haven't
uh they've taken for granted up until
this time
all because of a lack of workers behind
the scenes
it's interesting isn't it because um for
how long now has the hospitality sector
been saying
they just don't have enough people um to
fill the jobs and for the same reasons
um
they've given their um dawn just a
terrible
terrible story what what's going on um
this miami building i mean the question
is
why this is the sun page 29 it's picked
out
yeah quite kimberly this is um the sun
um
yeah it's quite way back in the paper
but obviously with everything else going
on
as you quite rightly say it's the
horrific story kimberly of the um
12-story tower block on miami beach that
collapsed i think it was on thursday
now um there's a frantic search going on
for 159 people missing still for
a confirmed dead um the sun have
found that there is a brit misty as well
a lovely lady called ravana patel her
husband
and their little girl who's only one and
and
was pregnant as well she's four months
pregnant they moved out there
for a new life she's a jewel our own
citizenship america
and brit and they are missing and
obviously their family and their friends
are desperately worried that as
indeed is anyone who has any loved ones
involved in this
people are still trying to get to the
bottom of what actually happened
kimberly but
it seems that um like a lot of miami
beach the building
was built on reclaimed wetlands and
evidently it has been sinking um for a
good few years now and it was due to
have another safety check
um in the next few months um sadly
obviously it just literally claps in on
itself like a pack of cards it's
absolutely horrific
and you can't quite believe this is
happening somewhere like miami um
but you know you just hope and pray that
they have already thankfully found
one little boy alive in the rubble so
rescuers are searching
you know as we're speaking now and and
hopefully they will find more people
alive they say they've heard knocking
but
you know you know thoughts and prayers
with everyone involved in this it's just
a horrific thing to happen yeah horrific
our
correspondent out there was talking to a
woman who was talking to her sister
on the phone who was in the building
when it collapsed it's just just
too terrible to even think of um
cyclists
now in the times page 11 biddyshire i
mean what do i know about cyclists apart
from there seems to be
a lot more around where i live but this
is more a bit more professional
what's this about well this is exactly
it kimberly because it's about going
from being an amateur cyclist or a
beginner athlete to
being a professional so ordinary this is
the weekend that opens up
the tour de france and other major races
it's the start of the season
and yet a host of major riders 12
very well-known professional cyclists
including chris froome and grant thomas
tour de france stars themselves have
pointed out that
again this is like my supermarket
shelves story because of the fallout
from ovid and brexit
these famous stars are going to be fine
but those beginning stages athletes who
need
visas and all sorts of work permits to
be able to
practice and compete and be part of the
industry
because of cycling of course is a major
sport with a lot of money behind it
they won't be able to step up those
early years of their career so
they haven't written to boris johnson as
the food and drink people did they've
written to oliver dowden
minister in charge of culture media and
sports saying
please look at this network again we're
going to lose a lot of talent
not us we're famous we're going to be
fine but all of these early stars who
need to make their names and compete and
really rise up the ranks by
participating in
great international endeavors like the
tour de france they're not going to have
the chance
to compete and be a part of this
international
sport so lots of different industries
are now basically coming out of this
last five-year period pandemic plus
brexit plus all the rest of it and
saying
where are we at and so i don't think
this is the first or the last of these
industry-based letters of protest that
we're seeing
it's interesting you never really think
about um work permits and things like
that logistics when it comes to athletes
do you
um dawn i don't have a ticket book do
you guys have a ticket porter
ill prepared um but demand up 3 000
this is the daily mail
absolutely um this comes obviously on
the back of the government
very generously um adding 16 new
destinations to the wonderful green list
they've climbed it up
and this includes the balearic highlands
malta madeira and some caribbean islands
and obviously it's like it's kimberly
it's not just holiday is it people
want to go and travel to see their
families to see loved ones
and you know the fact that we have not
been allowed it has just been so
frustrating and so many people are
missing out on so many important aspects
of families lives around the world
but you know since these countries are
narrowed to the green list and
as you say 3 000 percent demand
um on airlines tickets flights to these
places
and you know the airline's putting on
extra flights and it's fantastic news
but and there's always a but isn't there
with these stories
these countries have just been added to
the greenness could actually be
taken off the green list at any given
moment
within literally 24 hours now it's not
even that and it's very interesting that
grant chapter transport sector is
actually refused to say whether he would
book a holiday himself
and i think can be so many of us now are
terrified about well
if we get out there and then they change
the rules again
can we come back do we come back what do
we do how long we isolate
it's incredibly confusing and and as for
the ambulance
situation no idea what's going on with
that one i mean you know even the
government seemed confused on that one